hey I'm Nick from the container tools
team at Google and today I want to talk
to you about one of our newest and most
exciting tools scaffold scaffold is a
tool that's designed to make local
kubernetes development easy it watches
your local application directories for
changes and can automatically build push
and deploy your application images to
any local or remote kubernetes cluster
letting you focus on developing your
application let's take a look at how to
get scaffold running on your application
scaffold runs is a binary on your local
machine so installing it is as easy as
downloading the latest release from the
Google container tools github page
alternatively you can build scaffold
straight from source scaffold uses yamo
configuration to describe how your
application should be built and deployed
you can specify one or more images for
scaffold to build which scaffold will
tag and push to any valid docker image
repository these continuously built
images will be injected into your
kubernetes manifest and used to deploy
new changes to your cluster on every
code change let's walk through an
example to demonstrate a typical
scaffold workflow here we have a simple
go hello world application which just
prints hello world in a loop forever we
have a docker file that builds a binary
from the source file and puts it into a
container and a kubernetes manifest that
creates a pod from this container image
scaffold has a built-in command scaffold
in it that will generate a scaffold
animal for your codebase containing
default values to get scaffold running
let's run on the code that we have here
you can see our generated scaffold the
ml has one build artifact pointing to
our docker file that builds the image
and pushes it to our projects registry
this image is tagged with the git
tagging strategy which uses the latest
commit hash as an image tag though there
are several other tagging strategies
available scaffold also defaults to
using the coop control deployer that
deploys from our kubernetes manifest to
our existing cluster though there are
several other deployment strategies
available as well
as we run scaffold Deb you can see
scaffold immediately builds the artifact
we specified and pushes it to the target
registry it then creates a pod in our
cluster using the image we just pushed
by default scaffold streams the logs
from the pods it creates so looking at
these now we can see hello world being
logged like we expect one of scaffolds
most exciting features is its file
watcher which watches for changes to one
or more local directories on your
filesystem in real time when scaffold
sees any changes to your code
it will build a new image from source
and deploy it to your kubernetes cluster
let's change our print statement up and
watch how scaffold reacts as I changed
this string - hello scaffold we can
immediately see scaffold recognizes that
our source file has changed and REE
triggers a build and deploy watching the
logs we can see them switch over in real
time to our new print statement as a new
pot is created let's take a look at a
more complex example to see how scaffold
works with more realistic workflows here
we have an application with two services
a web server and an application server
these services can be built and deployed
independently of each other and scaffold
- smart enough to understand that let's
go through the same flow we did with the
hello world example here to see what it
looks like
running scaffold in it again this time
we're prompted for which docker file
builds each image since there's no way
for scaffold to know that beforehand in
our generated scaffold EML we can see
that a build artifact is specified for
each services source code directory and
scaffold we'll put a separate file
watcher on each of these directories
this means that when files change in one
directory but not the other
only the container corresponding to the
modified directory will be rebuilt
scaffold dev builds and deploys both
parts of the application as we expect
and in the logs we can see both services
are ready in our kubernetes cluster now
if I go make a change in the web server
we can see scaffold picks up the change
and only rebuilds that container
scaffolds deploy then only updates the
deployment associated with the newly
built artifact and we can see this
reflected in the deploy logs
this means your dev cycles are never
bottlenecked by parts of your
application that you're not working on
these services don't necessarily need to
live in the same repository as long as
your scaffold VM will points to valid
workspaces on your local file system you
can use any number of different
repositories in a scaffold workflow
making it an awesome tool for
development on micro-service based
applications scaffold can help speed up
any kubernetes development workflow by
getting ops out of your way allowing you
to focus solely on application
development you can find these examples
and more in the scaffold github
repository linked in the description of
this video
contributions to scaffold are always
welcome if you'd like to learn more
about contributing check out the
contributing guidelines in our github
repository go try it out for yourself
and let us know what you think copy
scaffolding
[Music]